the whole idea of the pension was to
provide public servants with a decent
retirement when they left public service
it wasn't to Manta to enrich them to
make them wealthy to allow them to
retire younger with more money and be
able to go off and play golf while the
rest of us supported them hi I'm Ted
baliker with Reason TV and today I'll be
sitting down with Jack Dean Dean is
editor and publisher of pension tsunami
comm and vice president of the
California foundation for fiscal
responsibility why don't you describe
briefly what pension tsunami comm is
well pension tsunami calm is a basically
a news aggregation website and what we
do is gather on a daily basis very early
in the morning we scour the the media
and see what kind of pension related
items may be showing up news stories
editorials commentaries blog posts in
many cases and then we take the best of
them and put them on the website for the
day so you're also vice-president of CF
f are for those who worried about the CF
RS and the global conspiracy it's
nothing to do with that
what's CF fr that's the California
foundation for fiscal responsibility and
it's an organization that was founded by
former Assemblyman Keith Richman after
he was termed out of the assembly and
it's a non-profit political organization
and its goal really is pension reform in
California in a nutshell what's the
problem with pensions in California and
elsewhere it's pretty universal that too
much has been promised to public
employees and the problem when you with
the public pensions is that they are a
contractual agreement that can't be
broken based on the California in the
federal constitution and so you have
situations where people are maybe 50
years old and they retire getting 90
percent of their their last salary is
that correct right well for public
safety the three percent at 50 is what
they is the gold standard I guess you
could say for the fire and police which
allows them at the age of 52
tire with 90% of their salary and then
of course if you take into consideration
the cost-of-living increases after that
you can see that over a period of time
they end up getting more in retirement
than they were actually getting while
they were working so it would be silly
for them to keep working after the age
of 50 or 55 and again and compare that
to Social Security we we think of that
as an entitlement something that we can
will get no matter what how is this
different there's a number of elements
and this is this is part of the problem
with trying to explain it to people is
there are so many pieces to the puzzle
one of course is the retirement age and
with Social Security you have everybody
has to wait until 62 with the earliest
and normally 65 and then now 67 which
they moved the the goalposts back for
the coming generations but with fire and
police for example if they have put in
their 30 years by age 50 they can retire
and begin collecting immediately so not
only are they getting more money than
you would get from Social Security by
far they're also starting to collect it
earlier they're also there thousands of
public employees in California that are
making upwards of six figures per year
just in pension benefits CalPERS as you
know will be they're mounting a response
they're catching a lot of heat they say
things like well the average pension is
only about 25 grand per year plus these
folks don't draw on Social Security like
most people do what's your response to
that actually there's several possible
responses the first thing that always
amazes me is that they bring up Social
Security at all because we'd gladly at
this point trade them if they want
Social Security we'll give it to them
and if it's an eliminate the pension but
in terms of the average pension I mean
that is obviously what they're doing is
to get the average they count everybody
they include everybody going back to the
oldest on the list going back 20 30
years the real problem has been created
during the past ten years since 1999
since SB 400 passed since all the
formulas were increased so is it fair to
say when we're comparing the u.s. to
Greece that
everyone's trying to say to what degree
is is this comparison fair it's really a
difference in degree but not a
difference in kind is that fair to say
well I think what I think what people
are looking at is the fact that the debt
is causing all of these problems and the
debt is not just any one thing in this
country for example you have to look at
the social security liability Medicare
than all of the state public pension
plans that are underfunded and then all
of the local pension plans that are
underfunded and to begin seeing this
number you know grow and grow to the
point where at some point we're not
going to be able to pay for those
pensions and do all the other things
that people want to do I want to read
you a quotation from Willie Brown that
I'm sure you've heard many times before
Willie Brown of course used to be
Speaker of the California Assembly for
many years
former San Francisco mayor earlier this
year he said this quote talking about
this is politically unpopular and
potentially even career suicide for most
office holders but at some point someone
is going to have to get honest about the
fact that 80 percent of the state county
and city deficits are due to employee
costs either we do something about it at
the ballot box or a judge will do
something about it in bankruptcy court
what does it say that someone with
liberal credentials like Willie Brown is
talking about this I think he
experienced firsthand what what was
happening and he has seen and continued
to grow in magnitude in fact he was
interviewed about two weeks ago I think
it was a Sacramento TV station and it
was a very brief comment the interviewer
asked him do you think that this will
cause the state to go bankrupt he said
no I don't think the state will go
bankrupt I think they'll just stop
sending out pension checks so you know
he's aware that this is a serious
problem in a lot of ways you can see
parallels between Willie Brown and la
mayor Antonio Villaraigosa
prior to being mayor he was a union
organizer now he's seen the other side
of that is he was in the assembly - oh
right exactly yeah
but going from the site from being
arm-in-arm with the unions to seeing
what excessive pensions can lead to and
now of course there's this Wall Street
Journal article lead author is dick
Riordan former mayor of Los Angeles
saying that based on LA's own
projections the city will be bankrupt by
2014 all right do you but are you buying
that do you think Los Angeles could go
the way of Greece according to a number
of economists that I you know keep in
touch with and there there's actually
been a number of pieces that have been
written blog posts on economic blogs
that Los Angeles San Diego and San
Francisco are already bankrupt they just
don't know it or they won't admit it and
that was a big problem with Greece is
that they they sort of cooked the books
to make it look better than it was
that's right now and I think another
another great quote in fact it's it's on
video
- it's on YouTube is Bill Lockyer who's
a Democrat or State Treasurer saying
that they need that something has to be
done about the pensions and that his
opinion is the legislature won't be able
to do it so or they're you know the
state will go bankrupt now as we know
the state actually can't declare a
bankruptcy so it means that there'll be
some kind of default in some fashion
that we may not even have envisioned so
what should be done about this well
that's a that's a hard question the only
thing that really can be done is that
benefits can be scaled back for new
hires there is no quick fix to it
politicians are always saying these days
a favorite chain of them is we have to
avoid kicking this can down the road
what happens if we continue to kick this
particular can down the road well I
guess it will mean that our children or
grandchildren will be faced with some
serious choices my personal feeling is
that something is going to have to be
renegotiated with the current retirees
the local governments for example in
Palm Springs of all places are
discovering they're having to do things
like close their Olympic swimming pool
in order to pay for the pension benefits
New York City they now have I think as
many retired policemen collecting
pensions as they have cops on the beat
the whole idea the whole idea of the
pension was to provide public servants
with a decent retirement when they left
public service it wasn't to Manta to
enrich them to make them wealthy to
allow them to retire younger with more
money and be able to go off and play
golf while the rest of us supported them
so I think and this attitude is growing
out there and the public people are
beginning to realize what's been done
and they're not happy about it